hallo ich meine lieben frauen und
herzlich willkommen zu einem sims 4
video mehr oder weniger wenn ihr davon
mehr sehen wollt nachdem wir diese folge
angeschaut habe dann schreibt es mir die
kommentare und spam den daumen nach oben
button und dann werde ich das ganze
eventuell normal spielen und ich würds
angefangen direkt an ich habe mich schon
ein bisschen vorgearbeitet und zwar wie
schon diese person gemacht den habe ich
tv kopf genannt weil er einen tv auf dem
kopf sieht natürlich jetzt extrem
sportlich hat der sonne so eine kleine
bier wampe hat eine netz hose an und
stiefel
er ist aber männlich meine der mann er
ist männlich er ist keine frau aber er
klingt ein wenig so wie ich das da er
ankam dass die zweite person ist es
mario mario er ist sehr selbstbewusst
und sein ziel ist sozial so viele leute
wie möglich kennen zu lernen hat eine
grüne hautfarbe das liegt daran dass er
zu viele popel gegessen hat und er heißt
mario mario weil er einfach diese
latzhosen hat und genauso wie mario aus
die dritte person ist jacqueline
heulsuse sie sonnen möchte gern
assassin's creed clown ähnliches teil
wenn man mal daran ihr gesicht
reinschaut
und sie hat einen sehr ausgefallenen
stil sie ist nämlich ein motto und das
ist unsere bude meine werten zuschauer
ich habe hier über diese kleinen
lämmchen aufgestellt weil es darin
relativ dunkel ist wir haben hier einmal
das badezimmer wir haben hier ein
kleiner schlafzimmer wir haben hier nur
ein doppelbett hier einen kleinen tisch
hier mit einem kleinen pinguine
fernseher dann haben wir hier das
bücherregal über ein paar lämpchen und
hier ist die küche es sieht noch nicht
ganz gut aus meinte aber das wird
natürlich noch wir haben natürlich noch
derzeit ihr seht schon 15 millionen
damit kann man sich nicht so die
krassesten hütten bauen die wir
beispielsweise hier sehen oder hier oder
auch hier einfach direkt neben uns dafür
haben wir natürlich noch kein geld aber
ich finde da wird noch einmal noch ein
paar fenster hin und hier auch noch und
die sind einfach alle nicht mehr
vergleichen höhe und dann begeben wir
uns wieder in den live modus und schauen
mal was die leute hier wollen
er fühlt sich unwohl schmutzig der
schmutz nimmt langsam überhand wird
schmutzig in fünf stunden nur gott datei
ist wir bauen dem jetzt erst mal
irgendeine der hat doch gar keinen sinn
der hat doch eine dusche duschen mann
beschwert ich jetzt nicht erst für
kinder weil ein kind in der nähe ist es
der behinderte wohn halt mit uns man
mario tut doch nicht zu hass etwas
gesehen was du niemals selbst mögen es
nicht wenn jemand einfach so herein
platzt ja gar keinen sinn ich hab doch
jeden habe ich in der tür
das ist doch eine tür wie sie geht der
marie ob dadurch der kann auch schließen
dieser tv zum essen rufen zur kinder es
gibt essen ihr aber da darf jetzt auf
jeden fall nicht mario zusätze nicht ob
mario kann sich auch gar nicht mehr
hinsetzen weil es war vielleicht ein
bisschen doof dass sich tv kommt die
eigenschaft gegeben habe dass er keine
kinder mag weder freund noch feind
einfach eine ganz normale beziehung okay
ich guck gehen für den
gemüt ich glaube wir müssen mario
irgendwie umbringen okay da der tv ja
keine kinder geben jetzt einfach mal zu
ihm hin erwarte die zudem hier vorne
lieber ganz witzig thema war so wir
stellen uns jetzt mal lustig mal
schlecht zubereitetem essen gegessen
er hat einfach selber gemacht er hat das
selber gemacht von vorhin und dann habe
ich noch einen kaffee getrunken
der war total lecker und jahrbüchern ich
auch mal gegessen und die hab ich muss
auf die toilette
deswegen gehen jetzt auch mal auf die
toilette jacqueline heulsuse schlechter
nachgeschmack weil tv koch nie wieder
bei uns im es hat mir angezeigt dass tv
inspiriertes vom kochen und jetzt sind
einfach alle schlecht drauf weil er so
scheiße gekocht hat okay da der tv kopf
immer noch so ein bisschen unwohl sich
führt und allgemein schlechten
nachgeschmack vom essen haben kocht
jetzt der mario einfach mal was und zwar
der kann gar nicht kochen post aufgabe
erledigen ist ein wichtiger schritt in
richtig gute noten auch in die rhi in
richtung gute noten soll mal was
leckeres kochen das können uns einmal
ausruhen
wir machen jetzt mal einen hamburger
kuchen hamburg die kocht fähigkeit
erworben ihre neuen fähigkeiten kann
jacqueline check lieder also dürfe
er ist okay ihm geht es gut wir schicken
auf die toilette um eine katastrophale
demütigung zu vermeiden hat er seine
hose noch an oder was ist dieser der
grüne fleck ist das ist dann ja marius
glücklich okay das ist wundervoll hätte
alles in ordnung dass ich das mal
irgendwann sagen könnt oder von mir
behaupten könnte im jacqueline heulsuse
die geht jetzt mal raus ob die street
und macht sich da ein paar leute klar
dass jemand ja wir gehen jetzt zu ich
dachte ich sollte meine geschichte
erzählen weil wir stellen uns einfach
mal lustig vor
da kommt jacqueline an gewalt das hot
tack auf zwei beiden ja guck mal allein
was macht die baukosten wieso kommt die
hand ob denn jetzt tv gucken hier geht
einfach mit tv-koch was willst du das
ist nicht deine unterhaltung die müssen
irgendwie weg schicken
der soll was mit mario hier die ganze
familie ist hier her richtig toben hier
steht so eine person diese kennenlernen
wollten und die meiner kompletten
mitbewohner teilt sich einfach hier und
stefan wird einfach total vernachlässigt
wenn mit ihr reden ja wir spielen jetzt
schach dass wir da dfb regte gerät von
tvtv und laura kennen sich noch nicht
okay aber ich hab dafür aufgegeben ich
bin hier tv co dann habe ich ihr tipp
gesehen und zahnräder ja und bücher mit
zahnrädern zusammenpassen
ja und noch mehr bücher bücher bücher
bücher ich mag bücher aber nein keine
kann man im fernsehen gucken die opfer
mal gut mal und freistoß oder okay sagte
fakt ist erstmal ganz gut beschäftigt
wir schauen einfach mal was machen die
beide werden die beiden gehört erstmals
und vergnügt doch da so ein bisschen
einfach aus wie ellen page von dieser
alan shore ich glaube da kriegen
heulsuse will sich irgendwie so einen
kleinen jungen klären oder irgendwie
bekommen und jetzt träumt sie von
schnellen autos
okay es ist 20 28 ich finde das ist eine
ganz gute bett geht zeit du gehst jetzt
erstmal schlafen
der mario geht auch schlafen und zwar
geht ihr zusammen schlafen nein es wird
kein fernsehen geguckt mario geht jetzt
ins bettchen tv kopf kommt jetzt aus
nach hause
danach geht der tv kopf nämlich auch
schlaf
und mario sollte war auf dem mal
aufwecken
ich weiß nicht 11 der weg den jetzt mal
wissen von tine füßen stehe
was hat er denn packard macht sondern
gesetz sei es geht eher dahin schlafen
meine ganzen mitbewohner schlafen
folklore ja toll was mario wieder wach
geworden na gut was hast du da für
bedürfnisse hat hunger
ok damit sich denn mario jetzt nämlich
erst mal was zu fressen machen und zwar
ab das nehmen wir doch erst mal mama
mama was ist das denn für ein riesiger
hamburger jetzt geht man mit dem mario
mal raus auf die streets und stellen uns
ein paar girlies vor weil der mario
möchte ja ganz gerne mal eine
bekanntschaft hier machen ich leben aber
eigentlich schon schön
wir leben direkt an so ein parkhaus es
halt nicht so schön aber da wird noch
verhindert wird was war die erste
episode sims 4 wenn ihr eventuell eine
zweite episode wollt dann schreibt in
die kommentare und spam den daumen nach
oben button in die höhe und dann war's
das auch schon